the way that these rookie contracts work
especially at the top they are very
front loaded with a big signing bonus
and josh rosen already has 11 million
plus yeah from the cardinals 6.2 million
remains over the next three years
combined that is a steal think about
that what it would cost to sign a guy on
the open market to play quarterback
you're paying
2.06 million roughly per year for josh
rosen over the next three years that's a
hell of a bargain for a team like
washington that is thinking about going
with colt mccoy who's making three you
go for josh rosen and i think the fact
that the contract is so favorable that's
what makes me skeptical about this idea
that that only a third round pick is in
play for josh rosen i think more than a
third round pick is in play because of
the contract because of the opportunity
because of the need out there it's not
the same need that we saw last year
right but there are plenty of teams that
have older starters that would love to
have the opportunity setting aside
washington for now which needs a
quarterback right with alex smith unable
to play whether it's the giants whether
it's the patriots a team that has an
older guy and they get a three-year
opportunity at 6.2 million to evaluate
josh rosen that's a hell of a deal
financially the question is what does it
cost you by way of a draft pick yeah
what does it cost you by way of the
draft pick and mike let's also not
forget there was a number of teams that
just were not in love with josh rosen
and you know the way he you know was
perceived let's say coming out of the nf
you know coming out into the nfl draft
there was a lot of question marks
whether you know he was a privileged kid
you know he
on social media you know through the
years at ucla had a few things that
certainly the teams didn't like you know
he didn't rub everybody the right way
okay i know let's hang on a second what
happened last year what happened last
year you're exactly right he was he was
professional as can be certainly so i i
i'm not the one saying i j i like the
rosen one in some of his antics i i
actually prefer and enjoy his honesty
and his challenging of the system
sometimes on social media but at the
same time you and i know a lot of nfl
teams and franchises and they don't love
people like that especially at the
quarterback position that scares them to
death at the face of their franchise
could be god forbid the robots have
brains that's exactly right that's what
they're worried about so that also plays
into this but your point about the money
being paid uh already certainly adds to
his trade value there's no question
about that i don't know if i would sit
here and go he's gonna fetch a first
round pick uh and i don't think i would
say he's gonna fetch a third round pick
but i think a second round pick when i
kind of just look at it i could see that
totally being a real option as we go
because still we still don't know what
josh rosen is totally as a quarterback
in the nfl he's still an unproven
commodity um and there is still going to
be the question about uh
can he take a beating at the quarterback
position that was another issue about
evaluating him kind of a narrow shoulder
guy
a little frail that way had an injury
history at ucla all those things i think
play into the factor of trading him and
i think ultimately some of those things
will stop it from being a first round
pick and maybe make it a second round
pick to a team who fancies them and
likes his skill set
all right let's get to the point then it
was something that was tweeted on your
twitter account i have a feeling that
you're not putting out many of these
tweets because you've been very
social media
but they're forcing you i'm trying
they're forcing you yes well well you
tweeted the question that we're going to
be debating now
who gets more in a trade josh rosen or
antonio brown mr big brain or mr big
chest right now rosen right hey i'm
surprised but i agree that rosen is
worth more in trade by way of what
you're getting by way of the importance
of the position how many years he could
end up being on your team and the total
financial investment remember that that
financial investment is a huge factor in
what a team gives up in trade because it
all goes into the same pot it is draft
picks plus whatever you have to pay and
there's value
in draft picks and if you if you can get
a guy for cheaper then maybe you give up
more by way of draft picks if you have
to spend a lot of money to get the guy
you're less inclined to give up those
draft picks so i think rosen should be
more valuable than antonio brown even if
it doesn't work out that way it's really
close it's a great conversation and
debate really because yes you made all
the points for josh rosen certainly
antonio brown is clearly the more proven
commodity and certainly one of the best
at his position in the nfl but then you
got to take into account is he going to
want a new contract you got to take into
account the baggage that might come
along with antonio brown you know is he
going to ruffle the feathers within our
locker room all of those things
certainly detract from the value of
antonio brown in a trade i am going to
say still though i think antonio brown
will fetch a little bit more than josh
rosen in a trade at this point i still
think antonio brown has looked at
throughout the league as one of the
three or four best wide receivers in
football and to the point i make with
josh rosen i think lessens the value
it's a weird year you know you talk
about washington washington's really the
only team we can look at right now and
go holy cow they need somebody
definitely now that we're hearing nick
foles is going to uh maybe be in
jacksonville so that's where i think
they that rosen's camp would fall into
the problem there is just is there
enough market there to kind of drive up
the trade price and maybe get it to the
first round so i lean towards antonio
brown in this convo
i want to mention something that came up
yesterday and i know you disagree with
it but it's not about whether you or i
disagree with you it's whether others in
the league
see any merit to this when you've got
scott mcclellan who was a successful
general manager ultimately was with
washington i think got ran out under
under hyped-up charges a couple of years
ago but
when mcluhan says that kyler murray is
the best quarterback in this draft but
not as good as the five last year that
includes rosen and that resonates with
me okay and i know you disagree with it
but if there are people who believe that
and the cardinals are thinking about
making murray the first overall pick in
the draft that just tells me there is
value in rose and it makes me wonder why
they're they're sufficiently smitten
with murray to throw rosen overboard but
if if there are other guys out there
that think that rosen is that good that
rosen actually is better than kyler
murray then that would drive up the
market as well ro i mean rosen is good i
i i really don't i mean as far as hey
decision making the ability to throw the
football mic i mean it's all there it's
there to be had he certainly can be
extremely effective as a pocket
quarterback in the nfl but i think
that's the the last phrase there pocket
quarterback this is the day and age of
you know eliteness and hey the
quarterback no longer for the most part
not everybody's got tom brady's
offensive line and game planning and
things like that to where he's gonna be
able to sit in a pocket and make
decisions and throws like that most
quarterbacks in the nfl are having to
move having to make plays off schedule
josh rosen saw that last year there
wasn't a lot of people open he didn't
have great pass protection well you know
what kyler murray's the type of guy that
oh i don't have great pass protection
watch me just run around everybody zing
zing zoom zoom and then all of a sudden
he finds somebody open so that's the
specialness of what kyler murray is he
is he brings some special physical
abilities to the table that yeah you
might be scared of his size okay yeah
josh rosa might be prototypical but kyle
murray can do some things that we've
seen very few quarterbacks come along
that can really do what he can do
well the clock is ticking more loudly
with brown than it is with rosie because
with brown the steelers remained very
motivated to clear him off the books
before march
minutes 17th i'm gonna win no i'm gonna
win and it was funny because i've been
thinking about uh you know what kind of
steak i want and whether i i've never
had one prepared medium rare
intentionally what i've gotten one that
i made at home accidentally medium rare
i typically go medium thank you but i
think i think when you buy me my steak
i'll i will order medium rare for the
first time why why i mean i i feel like
i mean why would you ever i don't
understand medium rare i don't
understand that's how you eat steak no
that's how you eat a dead animal on the
side of the road i don't understand that
i think so breathing immediately wait a
minute wait a minute you eat dead
animals on the side of the road i just
feel like it's like fresh kill still
it's like still bleeding in size medium
rare i can't do it uh we need a twitter
poll right now best temperature to order
steak medium well all right i'll do it
i'll do it during the blind medium well
yes just eat a hamburger for crying out
loud if you're going to get it medium
well that little thing of pink that's
just for show it adds nothing to the
flavor the [ __ ] it just that that little
line of pink just tells the world i am
not a complete and totally idiot
and i don't get well done
don't tell me about my taste buds i like
the way
medium well taste well you know what if
you win the bet i'll just give you a bag
of beef jerky to gnaw and it's the same
damn thing you know what i think if i
win the bet i'm gonna get a snake well
done and charred and still hope it's 65
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports